[Music]
I'm told you have studied c-span which
is no fun but you have studied c-span to
see how politicians behave with their
body languages have you picked anything
up I have indeed you know I this is what
I've noticed see see if you can follow
this so you know if you're watching a
politician like I'm doing right now and
I'm talking to you I'm going like this
politicians don't do a finger wave they
don't do this they don't point like that
I think it's because it it might seem to
I don't know in your face a little bit
of guy might seem a little aggressive
you may seem aggressive and they also
when they have a point to make they
don't do this because I think that
probably seems fascist or something
right you know if there's pictures of
you banging with your fists the subtext
is I'm an insane chimpanzee yeah I'll
tell you what they do do they do what I
call a fist they sort of make a fist and
then you move your thumb like this the
top of your fist like that and they talk
passionately about where they stand and
it goes like that really and they all do
it and it's moronic I mean I mean I mean
they're not all morons I don't mean to
say like that but no you're pretty much
said they're all morons yeah do this try
to them you go like this it doesn't feel
like a human gesture doesn't know it
yeah I know it's completely invented
unnatural yeah almost impotent in a way
do you think no I don't think it's
impotent at all I do really nice innit
I I'm mad about that for a reason which
is that I have been using this on the
show well you have yes I have for a
while I have we have actually have we
have this is just random selections from
our show no I'm serious
you should check this out
[Music]
you're running for office know that you
just said I'm impotent is what you said
man I don't know what to tell ya well
you're right but you don't have to say
it no it's true I just sort of died I
started to pick that up from politicians
as sort of a jokey thing and now a lot
of the times during the show I'm like
now you'll listen to me and yeah but
you're doing a bit you yourself Conan
you know I do it now in my real life now
to my wife I'm like you will get corn
bread you'll get corn bread and you'll
get Y all good and you'll do it now I do
that all the time and I'm sure she
responds very favorably to that it's me
really hard on the bridge of the nose
now this is are seeing years and years
you've done network television you've
had so much success there now you're on
HBO
New Horizons here I mean when you think
about it technically there's there's you
can do nudity you can you can not that
you would but you can yes you can swear
on can you what about you you can't
obviously can't do nudity here I've done
nudity but no one noticed the length of
my nude body was so bright
wearing a summer weight suit yeah this
suitcase in Pulp Fiction just what about
language can you use language on this
show there people can swear if if they
wish to Andy and I don't choose to swear
we try to avoid that but people people
can well Andy does a lot sometimes yeah
but when he's had a few but you can
swear but they they say it's this is
actually do they say it's okay if it's a
profanity but not a verb an active verb
oh yeah oh I see so you can't say you
you you can say I'm dying to that guy oh
no you can't say I'm
[Applause]
Oh
well
they will not be coming back do it man I
didn't tell you to do it baby you are
not gonna be the vice president now you
just blew your chances